the Google Terms of Service state that
our automated systems analyze your
content including emails to provide you
with personally relevant product
features such as customized search
results tailored advertising and spam
and malware detection so how does that
actually work well when I send or
receive an email in Gmail Google
software automatically scans the
contents of that message often searching
through it by keyword Google uses that
information to target advertising so
here Google can tell that I've been
emailing about China and it's offering
me holiday adverts if I click on that
advert Google makes money images work
differently though these aren't scanned
for content like text instead Google
maintains a database of child abuse
imagery that is taken down from its
search engine each of those images is
given a signature that uniquely
identifies it and works with child
protection agencies worldwide to create
this database of image codes and when
someone sends me an image it is matched
against that database to see if it has a
corresponding signature if it does that
image and its user are flag to child
protection agencies if it doesn't match
the image passes through the question is
is that massive scanning of emails an
invasion of privacy or even the most
die-hard privacy campaigner will
probably not argue against such measures
being used to track child abusers and
google says it scans only for child
abuse images not for other crimes like
burglary say and when it comes to
scanning users emails for commercial
reasons well unlike with the NSA or GCHQ
snooping there's a simple opt-out if you
don't like it use another email service
or encryption tools like Melville OOP
which lets you lock Gmail messages so
that they appear nonsensical to anyone
reading who you haven't given a key if
you're concerned about privacy and
there's lots to be concerned about you
can do something about it